In this problem, a half-gallon of the
hydrocarbon toluene with a molecular
weight of 93 g per mole, specific
gravity of 0.8, and a vapor pressure of
27 mm of mercury at 75° F
is spilled in a sealed room measuring 25
ft by 25 ft by 8 ft at 75° F.
What is most nearly the maximum
concentration in milligrams per cubic
meters of the hydrocarbon in the room
air?
Okay, so let's walk through this problem
step by step.
The problem is asking us to find the
concentration of the spilled toluene in
milligrams per cubic meter.
So, conceptually, we are finding the
mass in the air over the volume of the
room.
However, we also need to make sure that
this answer is not actually lower than
that. In other words, is the vapor
pressure limiting the amount that can
evaporate?
So, we will perform two calculations
here.
Step one will be to assume that
everything evaporates,
and step two will be to check that the
max possible evaporation
as limited by the vapor pressure.
So, let's start the first calculation.
The room volume is given as 25 ft by 25
ft by 8 ft.
This becomes 5,000 cubic feet, which if
we convert to meters,
gives us 142 cubic meters.
In step 1b, the total mass spilled in
milligrams will be converted from 0.5
gallons given in the problem statement.
So, we have a half-gallon.
So, 0.5
gal
times our conversion of
3.78
L per gallon
per gallon
times our conversion of 0.8
kg per liter
times
1 million
mg
in a kilogram.
And this will give us
just about 1 million 644,000
mg.
Now we can divide
1B by 1A
to get about 11,579
mg per cubic meter.
We can see that this is close to one of
our answers on the left.
However, we still need to see if
this is possible or if it's limited by
vapor pressure.
So in step 2A, we are going to convert
our vapor pressure to parts per million.
Since the problem gives us the vapor
pressure in 27 mm of mercury,
we can divide that by 760 mm of mercury
and then multiply by 1 million to get
about 35,526
parts per million.
Now in step 2B, we can use the provided
molecular weight and the parts per
million calculated above to get the
answer in milligrams per cubic meters.
The equation used in this step is given
in the reference manual on page 53.
So setting up the first equation,
we can see that
ppm
times
our given 93 g/mol
over
our 22.414
liters per mole
will give us just about 147
milligrams
per cubic meter.
So, this is the max possible
concentration according to the vapor
pressure.
This means
that our first answer is totally
possible
and therefore correct for this problem
since it is much less than the max
possible concentration. In fact, if we
had known to stop here, we wouldn't have
even needed any special equations, just
the unit conversions carried out in step
one. So, this problem requires a little
bit of knowledge that the reference
manual doesn't give you. Namely, you
need to know that if you have vapor
pressure in millimeters of mercury, you
can divide by 760 and multiply by 1
million to get parts per million.
You also need to know that the reference
manual contains information on how to
convert parts per million to milligrams
per cubic meters
and also what to use for the molar
volume, even though there aren't many
useful keywords in the problem that will
prompt you to search for these things.
Also, the manual has the conversions
used in step one if you forget them.
For problems like this, I found that the
main benefit of practicing them is
learning that they could exist and that
certain material does exist in the
reference manual for you to use if you
come across a similar problem on the
exam.
And as always, if you have a better way
of solving this problem, I'd love to
hear about it in the comments. And
that's it.